let's go next to phil from california
phil you're on the air
hi can you hear me yes i can
hi david i had a question about uh
propaganda in general
okay and it seems like with propaganda
it seems to have origin where there's a
voluntary actor who kind of promulgates
the initial idea of prop propaganda and
disperses it
but at what point does the propagate
propaganda become like a feedback loop
and people that are propagating it also
are consuming it and falling for it oh
it happens very quickly oh sorry go
ahead yeah
i was going to just say for example it
seems like putin may have fallen for his
own propaganda with his initial attack
on the ukraine and how poorly his uh
army performed
was probably partially to believe in his
own
uh
propaganda about liberating ukraine and
that he would be welcome with open arms
i'm not sure about that i i don't i
don't think putin was that naive but i
think your principle is very much there
i i see it much more
like in the current republican party
where
i see it the other way where it's sort
of the people that fell for the
trump is really the winner propaganda
end up spreading it
and then they end up believing it
because people they've convinced start
repeating it themselves so that's the
feedback loop that i've seen
i don't know that the putin example i
don't know if i don't know how sure i am
of the putin example but your idea is
absolutely spot on
thank you david my pleasure thank you
very much for the call
a nice concise call there